let's bring in skies lisa dowd hello to
you lisa that guilty verdict for
penelope jackson uh for the murder of
her husband can you tell us more
well there was no reaction from penelope
jackson as the
jury of four men and eight women found
her guilty of her husband's murder now
to all intents and purposes it had
seemed that this couple had had a close
and loving relationship for the last 20
years their daughter had given evidence
in court and she said there had been
some serious aggression from her father
directed to her mother in the late 1990s
but more recently everything had seemed
fine in their relationship but penelope
jackson had claimed that in fact she
lived in fear of her husband that he had
been coercive and controlling
over the 24 years of their marriage he
had shaken her he had kicked her
he had strangled her
to the point of unconsciousness and she
said
that back in february during the winter
lockdown she had lost the plot and
stabbed him three times at their home in
somerset after he had called her
pathetic following a family meal over
zoom
now
it was david jackson who had initially
made a 999 call to the emergency
services for help and
in that
909 call he could be heard screaming as
he was apparently stabbed and we can
play you an extract of the 999 call now
where the call handler is speaking to
penelope jackson
are you with him now
well i might just go and stab him again
all right do not stab him again
why
okay so just listen to my voice
okay stay on the line with me i am
complacent okay are you with the patient
now
well i'm in the land
he said i wouldn't do it again
so okay so in total how many times
three times three times
once i thought i'd get his heart well i
haven't
now a short time after that 999 call
police arrived and they filmed on their
body cameras
mrs jackson being arrested
in the footage she tells the officers
that she admitted it all
she directs the officers to the kitchen
and one officer when they call out for
an ambulance pronto they say for cpr
she replies oh no no i should have
stabbed him a bit more
she later tells an officer on that video
that he was an aggressive bully and she
had had enough now she always admitted
killing her husband but she had denied
murder and what the jury had to decide
and consider was whether she had lost
control
in continuing to stab her husband during
that 999 call given the years of abuse
that she claimed she had suffered now
they decided today that she was in
control when this happened and that she
is guilty of murder currently the court
is hearing
victim impact statements and it may well
be that she is sentenced today as well